team was led by names and legends like
manny ramirez pedro martinez keith folk
and big poppy david ortiz now if that
feels like a lifetime ago get this
right now all four men have sons playing
for the same summer league baseball team
their home field just 25 miles south of
boston's fenway park a unique twist on
the boys of summer
thank you
manny ramirez jr grew up watching his
dad sign autographs with the boston red
sox
this is like something that only happens
like once in a lifetime
now it's his turn as a member of the
brockton rocks
martinez grounds this one right the
first of the four red sox offspring to
join the club was pedro martinez jr
honestly it feels like a movie i'm not
gonna lie to you like it feels so fake
like wait wait this is happening the
other two pedigreed players are deangelo
ortiz david ortiz's son and kade folk
cade's dad keith closed out boston's
historic world series win in 2004. what
do you remember about when you first got
on the team and then realizing oh oh
wait oh oh oh
like a surreal experience because
i um coming in i really didn't know how
it was going to be
this became natural or normal that they
were on the team and you know we just
became good teammates and good friends
those friends include a couple more
major league offspring jose martinez son
of former dodgers pitcher ramon and
nephew of pedro senior along with jayden
sheffield dad gary a nine-time all-star
whose yankees lost to boston and route
to that 2004 sox title i feel like
jayden for you at
enemy territory
over here i mean yankees and red sox are
not supposed to get along they
definitely give me a little bit of slack
for it like we definitely talked about
like the 2004 world series and just
prior to that they'd find something else
if it wasn't this right yeah
of course none of them were actually old
enough to have lasting memories of 2004.
i was a year old
so i was 11 months old i mean from what
i've been told i was just like a bad kid
like i remember i used to
i used to go into the locker rooms and
like lock people out of their phones and
like call people and stuff like i think
i i think i grabbed jeter's phone one
time and like texted a bunch of people
off of his phone i definitely do
remember
like the parades
and like after they won it i remember
being scared of mickey mouse when we
went to disney
what they all remember clearly is
realizing that their dad's day jobs were
anything but ordinary once i started
playing it more and i knew that i wanted
to do it forever
and i would see the things that like my
dad did i'd see the things that like
their dads did i'd be like whoa like
these guys are legit
jose what is the best thing about having
a dad who has been a major league player
the knowledge that it comes with
he just knows exactly the right steps to
take what i got to do and he's just a
great partner what's the hardest thing
the expectations
the expectations is to a whole different
level like especially me i'm a pitcher
and both my my uncle and my dad are
pictures how do you not
let the expectations that others have
become your expectation
well i just go into every game with no
expectations just go out there and let
my talent do
do what it does and i just go out there
and play i try to just be the best i can
be not try to be like anybody else not
try to
do something that someone else did like
i'm going to be the first
me
martinez jr says that's actually some of
the advice his dad has given
and let's get it him
all of the dads spending time around the
brockton rocks this season this is what
you do when you're a hazmat come out
here push dirt around when we visited
keith folk was giving the grounds crew a
hand how has it been for you
to help groom not just your son but some
of your former teammates sons as well
yeah it's been incredible being a big
league ballplayer is great but there's a
lot of struggles involved if we can make
a young athlete's path a little bit
easier make him a little bit wiser on
the field and off the field you know
that's that's kind of being that mentor
and we take pride in that no matter the
player
the other day like i had kids dad try to
help me work on some like their own
motions i had manny's dad come and help
me with the cage and he kind of saw some
things that my dad was trying to explain
to me and wasn't articulating in a way
that i understood when it's your dad
still yeah even no matter how great your
dad is right sometimes you don't like to
listen because it's your dad yeah i'm so
serious like my dad will repeat the same
thing over that's very strong yeah he
knows that like and like you'll get like
mad
his dad or like manny or david or his
dad will like say it and i'm like oh
you're right
and like you don't want to admit that
like your dad was right yeah just the
way they interact with everyone is just
one experience tom tracy is the rock's
general manager and says the input from
these major league dads is an unexpected
bonus thanks to a roster about which you
could say the same so was it intentional
or
mix of intentional and circumstance a
mix absolute mix intentional
circumstance um you know when when i'm
building the roster i'm not thinking oh
who can i get that's a former
professional player some because that's
not how you build the roster because the
game of baseball doesn't care about the
name on your back and cares about how
are you developing them getting ready
and every single one of them their their
attitude is i gotta show i'm a good ball
player
and to make it in the majors a great
ball player until then this group says
the name on their jerseys is no
different than any other we're not
special yeah we didn't do anything
we did nothing it's like nine hour days
yeah and then when you get to college
it's even worse because like you still
have class and like
you gotta be up at like five in the
morning six in the morning doing a lift
practice
you gotta get extra cage work you gotta
do like extra lifting on your own or
else you're not even gonna you're not
gonna have a shot it doesn't matter your
last name yeah it's not baseball doesn't
care about your last name i'll tell you
that yeah when that baseball hits you
i don't care who you are
absolutely love spending time with these
young men so a couple things they're in
the futures league and this is a
collegiate summer league and what it is
it's before you start college or in
between college it gives you that chance
to develop and play the brockton rocks
this season their gm told me they have
more than tripled attendance because
people knew
wanted to go want to see these kids but
also the dads surprisingly one day you
show up and oh there's manny manny's
there for practice a lot but also ends
up showing up for a game perhaps or
pedro whoever may show up that day maybe
the red sox should call him up might
help oh that hurt that hurts that hurt
but i love that it was more than even
just the red sox and then the ribbing
that you got between them just really
beautiful to see these guys try to you
know chart their own course and really
step out on their own it was sweet i
love the story from top to bottom thanks
misha